i want to start with i've seen the first
five episodes of season four it's
fantastic uh fans are going to love it
um and i was really surprised at the
scale and scope of the series and i'm
cure of this season and i'm curious if
you could talk a little bit about your
reaction when you started reading the
scripts and you saw oh my god this is
pretty massive
yeah my reaction was uh let's hope so
pay for this and that we uh we don't
have to cut too many scenes you know
um that's always the thing when you get
a script that's like epic and amazing
and the wide scope you i'm always
looking at the thing and being like okay
lithuania's gonna be like some corner of
a set with like a little fake snow or
something so the fact that they let us
like i mean russia the fact that they
let us go to lithuania like work in
these environments have this cinematic
landscape like we were in a prison in
lithuania we were actually working on a
railroad out there in the snow and the
tundra there's snowmobiles like that
sort of scope and scale i never thought
they could let us do and they really
like delivered so i was very happy that
they didn't shortchange it yeah and then
you know me as a narcissist i read the
script and i was like oh my god i'm like
i'm in it a lot more this is amazing
yeah
oh my god more of me fantastic and no
but also like my initial reading that
i got to uh you know
yeah in this like comedy duo with winona
was just like beyond exciting to me and
then of course that like you know we got
to all join up with david again was just
like
you know getting the band back together
was an amazing uh you know i was really
really excited i always just assume that
they're going to make it all happen you
know but uh
yeah yeah but the other one is worried
about budgets
like it'll be fine because i'm only
thinking of myself
i i and i also i absolutely um
well i love that it kept the
the heart part of
it you know that that there is with all
of this massive stuff going on there is
like a beating heart and there's love
there in all of the storylines really
um
and i also really loved working with
with nico
he was such an
absolute legend yeah
comic genius to work with yeah he's just
i can't wait for people to meet him and
and
i we only got to have like a scene with
ed eduardo but he's also absolutely yeah
like just gonna i think people will love
him yeah when you guys started reading
the scripts for season four uh did any
of you correctly guess where it was
actually going by the end or was it
completely you had no idea no idea i'd
say i mean uh it was really
there's an amazing
unpredictability this season i mean
winona you were saying before uh in a
another interview about how
how you just like you really have no
idea what's gonna happen and uh
and yeah it was just exciting fun to
play when you when you absolutely have
no idea when
you have no idea what's going to happen
in the next
moment
it's it's exciting to play that as an
actor you know it's also exciting to do
the the more um
deeper
scenes which there there are
um but i there
can't give yeah i mean i will say that
there there's uh you know in terms of
the general the structure and the way
that things happen uh you can never
predict as you look at the script but i
did know that i didn't know going in
that there were certain like
posts that we really wanted to land
because
this season
even in its bigness is sort of a this
big rush to the finish which will happen
in season five and i and i did look for
and sort of know that there were these
very specific posts that we had to lay
down so we could pay them off
later on so those things weren't a
surprise but the way that it happens
was very surprising on that note i need
to stop i'm just going to say congrats
on the season and i know fans are going
to love it
you